excuse me where's the lobby down the
hall and to the left
thanks Home Alone 2 director Chris
Columbus described the delicate process
of getting Trump onto the Silver Screen
the secret it seems lay in wanting to
borrow his stuff Columbus mentioned that
to shoot in most New York City locations
you pay a fee and you're allowed to film
there for Home Alone 2 the production
approached The Plaza Hotel which Trump
owned at the time for permission to
shoot some scenes in the lobby Columbus
further elaborated Trump said okay we
paid the fee but he also said the only
way you can use the plaza is if I'm in
the movie so we agreed to put him in the
movie and when we screened it for the
first time the oddest thing happened
people cheered when Trump showed up on
screen so I said to my editor leave him
in the movie it's a moment for the
audience but he did bully his way into
the movie